ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
Hi everyone, we're
here at Devoxx 2014.
I'm here with Martin.
MARTIN GORNER: Hello everyone.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Hi Martin.
And we're here to
talk about Polymer.
Because you have been very busy
at this conference advocating
Polymer.
MARTIN GORNER: And a lot of
people were there to see it.
There is a lot of interest
around Polymer today.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: I think
indeed there was
a lot of interest.
So what are people
interested, and why do you
think they're interested?
What is Polymer,
and how does it fit
in the-- we're talking
about web here, and taking
the web forward.
MARTIN GORNER: So taking
just a little step back,
the important thing
here is web components.
That's the standard evolving.
And allowing you to use
and create components
that you'll be able to
import into your page,
and that are self-contained,
encapsulated,
have a proper interface.
Well, everything you have been
used to in high-level languages
for years, but this
did not exist in HTML5.
Finally the standard is
evolving to bring this back.
You will be able to have
libraries of components
built using various
technologies.
You don't care.
It just works.
It doesn't break your page.
You put them in, boom.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And so we're
talking about
in-source code using
tags, which are
the implementation.
So as a user of those
components, it's very easy.
It's tags attributes
and you're done.
MARTIN GORNER: It's
easier than that.
It's one tag.
A web component is one tag.
So you have a special button
that someone created for you
with beautiful animations,
and your company colors,
and whatever.
To use it in your
page, you just use
one tag, which is
My Custom Button.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
So web components is actually
multiple specs, am I right?
And that is
specification by the way,
this is not a Google thing.
This is we're
talking something--
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
It's four specifications--
Shoadow DOM, Template, Custom
Element, and-- I
always forget one.
Template.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Template.
Thank you.
So these are something
that is agreed
upon among a number
of vendors, and that
makes up the web components.
And then at Google,
obviously, we
talk a lot about
material design.
And obviously, there's
probably an intersection
here between material design,
building things for the web
and having this unified
way of building and UI, UX.
MARTIN GORNER: So material
design is a design philosophy.
I encourage everyone to go and
check out google.com/design.
It's all there.
And frankly, I find
it a fascinating read.
It reads like a novel.
It's all the philosophy
of material design.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And you're
more of a developer
than a designer,
it's probably worth mentioning
that it is good for developers
to read this.
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
It is.
All developers should
be design-minded,
and it's a great
resource for developers
who want to become
design minded.
And it just happens
that Polymer,
which allows the building
of reusable components,
comes with a library
of paper components
which are based on the
principles of material design.
So yeah, it's there.
Try them out.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Yeah, so Polymer
is the web implementation
of what Android Lollipop is
bringing in terms
of implementation
of material design.
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
Polymer is actually two things.
Polymer, at its core,
is a set of polyfills.
Because the web standards
we were talking about,
they are not yet
supported everywhere.
So the Polymer polyfill brings
all browsers to the same level.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
MARTIN GORNER: This hopefully
will go away one day.
And on top of that,
there is the value
added of Polymer, which is
basically syntactic sugar.
To make the building
and using of components
a more enjoyable experience
for the developer.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
Tell us more about that
enjoyable experience
of building the
component itself.
MARTIN GORNER: So one
way to see it is, first,
if you hear about those
four specifications--
Imports, Templates, Shadow
DOM and the fourth one
which I keep
forgetting-- actually
creating your own custom
element using the new low level
JavaScript requires--
it's not so complicated,
but it does require quite
a few lines of JavaScript.
It's not so simple.
So what Polymer brings
is a syntax, using tags,
that allows you to define
your own component.
And that is a lot more usable
than the low level JavaScript.
It's too much work.
It's nothing fancy,
but it's too much
work using the
low-level JavaScript.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
So take the boilerplate
out of the way.
So once I have those
components, am I
forcing anybody who wants
to use one of my components
to use a Polymer?
You know, I'm using all
sorts of JavaScript libraries
and frameworks and all that.
Does it play well
with all those things?
MARTIN GORNER: Well,
that's the beauty.
Those web components,
you can build
them using whatever technology,
whatever framework is there,
that produces web components.
When a user will import this
component into his page,
once the JavaScript that
handles all the syntactic sugar
is executed, at
the end of the day,
that component ends up in
the dump as a web component
that the browser
understands natively.
So this means that you will
be able to mix and match
components built using various
frameworks, and they will work.
And the fact that there
are proper components
encapsulated-- their
HTML is encapsulated,
their CSS is encapsulated,
the JavaScript
that defines their
behavior is encapsulated.
They will not break your page.
They should not interfere
with each other,
they should not interfere
with the other libraries
you're using.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So encapsulation is great,
but at some point you need
to interact with and not
just use it.
Are there ways to
customize this and expose
parts of the implementation?
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly.
They have a
customizable surface,
but one that you define.
So the simplest way is to
define custom attributes.
And you specify what
these attributes
are going to do
in your component.
For instance, you can
have a heading attribute
in a component.
And the definition
of the component
will display that
heading somewhere
as the CSS and the HTML of
this component defines it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So from what you're saying--
I mean this is the web.
In terms of, use any tool you
want, any framework you want.
We're not forcing people with
Polymer to use a new framework,
have this dependency, or use
this set of tools, or tool
chain.
You really still are using
whatever framework you want.
And at the end of the day,
this is all web pages.
MARTIN GORNER: Yes,
and I do believe
that in a couple of
years, there will
be multiple frameworks for
generating web components.
Polymer is one.
Mozilla is creating one actually
based on the same polyfills.
Which means that, even now,
before web components are fully
implemented in browsers, since
they use the same polyfills,
those elements will be
compatible, even now.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: That's great.
So how mature is
this whole thing?
You know, web components, we're
using these polyfills now.
But that's certainly
a very viable thing.
MARTIN GORNER: So it's very
bleeding edge right now.
You can look at the support for
the four specs on [INAUDIBLE].
The short version is that those
specs are implemented fully
on Chrome only, and they
are under various stages
of implementation
on other browsers.
So that's totally
bleeding edge. it
doesn't work today in a
cross browser environment.
The polyfills themselves,
in Polymer-- so Polymer
itself is in version
0.4, which means
that the polyfills and
their cross browser support
is in the same kind of state.
I would not put it into
production today, of course.
You should wait for a 1.0 to
put anything into production.
But the promise is that--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
There are breaking changes.
MARTIN GORNER: Exactly, there
are still breaking changes.
But the promise is, once
Polymer reaches 1.0,
those polyfills
should be stable.
The libraries of elements
that come with Polymer
should be stable.
And you will be able to
deploy web components cross
browser thanks to the polyfills.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
That sounds pretty promising.
So in the meantime, you were
running a code lab here,
which I believe is
available online
which people can follow
at their own pace.
So we'll have links in
the show notes to that,
and I think that's
probably something
that people should
check out and--
MARTIN GORNER:
Please try it out.
It's a very simple application.
And in it, you can
see how fast you
can build something
that looks great.
Because it uses the paper
elements with material
design behind it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Great.
So I hope you try this, you
follow Polymer as it evolves.
And start using
it as soon as you
find it mature enough
for your needs.
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN GORNER:
Thank you, Alexis.
And we'll be seeing you online.
Cheers.